hailing Republican Senator John McCain
who Donald Trump of course called not a
war hero is confirming in his new book
that yeah he gave the Christopher Steele
Trump Russia dossier to FBI director
James Comey fired FBI director James
Comey who was at the time not yet fired
McCain's new book is called the Restless
wave and McCain writes in the book which
is coming out in a couple weeks a little
under two weeks he said quote I agreed
to receive a copy of what is now
referred to as the dossier I've reviewed
its contents the allegations were
disturbing but I had no idea which if
any were true I could not independently
verify any of it and so I did what any
American who cares about our nation's
security should have done and for me the
shock here is not that John McCain made
this decision most people that have
followed John McCain's political career
can disagree with the guys
neoconservative views which of course I
do but wouldn't be shocked for the exact
reason that McCain says that he felt it
was his duty to pass this on to the FBI
and that that's why he did it
and for me the more interesting part is
the detail that McCain explains in the
book about the path of the dossier to
him and ultimately to FBI director James
Comey which confirms that this was not
some extraneous wacky gossip file right
this was a serious document put together
by a respected former intelligence
officer Christopher Steele and passed
through official and respected channels
like for example McCain writes in the
book that he spoke with Sir Andrew wood
in November of 2016 about this wood is a
former British diplomat and would told
McCain that hey this dossier exists it
was put together by Christopher Steele
so you've got a respected diplomat
saying the source of the dossier in
Christopher Steele is also respectable
right it's not a sir would going to John
McCain and saying we have a PP file we
right I mean this is a serious
conversation among about respectable
individuals McCain takes woods seriously
so he sends David Cramer who's Senior
Director for human rights and human
freedoms at the
kein institute sends david Kramer to
London to directly have a meeting with
Christopher Steele and we also learned
that even before Steele met with David
Kramer from the McCain Institute Steele
had already been to Rome
to meet with American officials about
the findings in his dossier right so the
dossier has been framed by the Trump
astride as effectively equivalent to
like a gossip magazine or a tabloid that
due to some terrible decision-making
ended up in the hands of the FBI the
truth is the opposite right this was
handled very seriously and soberly
because at every step of the way
Christopher Steele and Sir Andrew wood
and American officials in Rome and John
McCain and the FBI everybody was taking
it seriously as a document with a
respectable source the veracity of which
had yet to be confirmed it's not the
gossip rag that the Trump is right likes
to make it out to be
yeah and McCain did the right thing here
even though he doesn't like Trump he did
the right thing by going to the FBI with
the dossier could you imagine if say
Devin Nunez got a dossier about Barack
Obama yeah it was filled with damaging
information against the former president
he would go right to the public with it
I think absolutely and I think that
that's an element of it but also just
make a counterexample sort of thought
experiment right imagine that McCain got
this and didn't pass it along and then
of course over time we know that the
allegations in the dossier relating to
Carter page and different interactions
there's a long list of stuff not the PP
tape but a long list of stuff in the
dossier that's been verified imagine if
all of those stories came out
individually and a year and a half later
John McCain says oh you know what I was
given a dossier that said a lot of this
stuff 18 months ago and I just didn't
think to mention it to anybody or pass
it along official channels he'd be
slammed for that the obvious right thing
to do was what John McCain did and the
idea of criticizing him for it to me is
absolutely and totally ridiculous
definitely what a tarnished McCain's
reputation absolutely and maybe even
more maybe legal repercussions although
there are outstanding circumstances in
his case of course ya know no doubt
about that so the I think the genesis of
this dossier has been a big element of
trying to sort of
take it down and almost everything that
we've heard about the genesis of the
dossier has been untrue and by the way I
I did a debate earlier this week or late
last week on the Tom woods show where I
debated former CIA analyst Ray McGovern
about Trump Russia and he would mention
offhandedly multiple times during the
debate that nothing from the dossier has
been confirmed and it's simply untrue
right like at this point they are just
saying demonstrably false things and
that continues to be part of the
narrative
Christopher Steele was unreliable the
dossier was nothing more than a gossip a
salacious gossip magazine and an article
or whatever and nothing in it has been
proven true all of which of course have
been proven to be false the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad